hello and welcome to a new video this is
the first video of the year so I wish
all of you a good start for 2012 I hope
you had a good christmas day so maybe a
couple of three days also um after quite
a long break and playing couple of games
i hope to upload more videos now
regularly again I'm still playing a lot
of video game I started to play a couple
of weeks ago but ok I've explored to
almost all there is in this game so i
guess i'm back to chest now I already
started request for a game but I didn't
get one yet and also I must say that um
that I haven't basically played at all
the last couple of weeks so besides a
couple of tournament games so most
likely i'll be a bit bit rusty if i get
a game started haha it's very loud ok i
need to need to change this ok let's
let's play opponent is called Asian
gambler we got them before you five
opening let's see how it's going for on
the Italian game and also here the
Sharps line with my g5 so check I most
likely sacrifice appear upon add this
line now now I recently saw that this is
getting popular somehow not sure I think
95 so may move now I don't thinks this
is played so often they mostly go I to
e4 which is the idea basically a Bishop
d3 not sure
I'm 56 looks like a normal Mouse yeah
interestingly five now assume is may be
threatened so I could go thing should be
forward to pin just come up with rookie
aid or what what else can I do an idea
for maybe it's also an idea but you will
most likely just retreat to f1c will
need to do anyway I'm not sure what rook
e8 because maybe the rook is good on f8
when I play at five at some point also I
could also play Queen c7 but I want to
have this route open to f6 maybe not
sure okay hmm need to play something
this has the added idea if he's going
now Bishop f1 that I can play you for ya
okay but now what about f5 the director
five I got very nice central control
from a pawn and you fall of course is
threatened not sure yeah but then I play
it for now why where does he go to to d4
doesn't have some so many great squares
yeah
okay what now maybe is sometimes
threatening on c6 goes d 5 is heading
because maybe on Queen f6 for instance
you can maybe take on c6 but I can take
on c3 so this looks like a good move
okay just retreats I could I could
exchange my bed night now it would open
up the a file but yeah if I for svet p
so I should just exchange
I'm pretty certain it's a good position
but not so easy to see how to continue
after F for this oneness maybe hanging I
could prepared with Queen f6 of course
but he will play these three months
slightly maybe I could should just take
and play a 4 immediately okay let's go
for this don't like very much to take
because okay where was more expecting to
him to take with the deep on to get some
development que creen g6 now with Bishop
g4 coming up Bishop g4 should be a
threat now because if he interposes was
Bishop e2 I've got f3 so not sure what
will he play now d three maybe yeah if I
go Bishop g4 now he would have Queen f
23 22
I need to speed up a bit 22 what what
then hmm not sure Bishop f3 maybe the
idea to take on g2 and then f3 but you
will have Queen g5 in this kind of this
kind of line
or maybe maybe still the smooth and then
then try to find something else after he
captures if he captures not sure what
kind of I cannot take and f3 because of
this night of the screen g5 business I
could I could just prepared with age 6
which looks terribly slow but maybe
that's an idea
but he could could play king h1 of
course
I could play King edge one also now but
then I could I could I think I could
take that on time warning ok took the
will check again I cannot take it f3
because I just this stupid Quincy five
maybe
yeah the time the time mr. is an issue
it's terribly complicated I only got 30
seconds takes on g2 now roop do one is
made
terribly low one time of course position
is some I think simply winning check
okay he gave me this this extra rock now
check even if my velocity state don't
need to turn down the volume terribly
loud checkmate yeah okay yeah
complicated Jana complicated position it
look very nice but not sure let's check
check this quickly with the engine here
yeah the egg engine just likes white
interesting
I have the window set up a bit stranger
so I cannot even see the computer moves
properly yeah it gives this position
with the plus three for White yeah what
is it actually I've got five pawns wyd
got six points yeah maybe this is not a
serious attack it's possible but it
looked at look promising I think this
this shouldn't shouldn't be that bad but
it steadily gives white an advantage a
surprising name yeah well at least it's
not not easy to play in the practical
game I think well thanks for watching
and I'd start a new game soon